representing the national Farmers Union
Minette batters height good to see you
president of course hi you're going to
Downing Street I certainly am oh tell us
about what's going to happen what do you
want to achieve from that meeting so I
think it's it's really significant this
was a commitment by the Prime Minister
on the campaign Trail back in August we
actually wrote an open letter asking for
a commitment to domestic food security
we've got 70 million people living here
on an island nation food security
matters and so he committed to it then
and I'm delighted that he's actually
doing it now everybody will have
experienced at some stage you know
either not being able to buy eggs or the
rationing of salad ingredients indeed
eggs still quite a big issue we had a
billion less eggs produced last year
compared to 2019 and these are sort of
Staples household Staples and people
just want to be able to buy 24 7. so
it's very much looking at how we give
producers the confidence to keep making
these big Investments so fairness in the
supply chain dealing with resilience how
we produce effectively more of what
we're good at here one of the actual
complications of course with X was bird
flu and and not as many eggs were
produced as a result but
what can the Prime Minister actually do
the one thing the Prime Minister can do
is to bring the whole of government
together so we very much work with dafra
but also there are huge issues obviously
in the home office with access to people
with trade with business and this is an
opportunity to bring everybody together
to look at how we deal with these huge
issues of inflationary costs that
everybody will be facing into and of
course the farmers that I represent 47
000 farmers and Growers across the
country who are facing 50 percent cost
inflation of their input so we've got to
drive down inflation costs we've said
for a long time that actually for
poultry producers and for Growers they
ought to be able to access the ETI
scheme that's the energy intensive
scheme at least they know their energy
costs certainty on on labor and
Workforce of course so we've got to
drill down on cost of inflation in
production in order to make sure that
food is Affordable for consumers and
that's there let's drill down our labor
a bit more should we labor from Europe
should they be allowed to come in should
we relax the rules so that they could
come in to pick fruit and vegetables and
others so this has been a huge huge
issue and we were when we were members
of the European Union we were the
preferred country to work in out of all
member states people wanted to come here
most of all because it's highly
regulated it's well paid and of course
that freedom of movement has ended so
now these Visa schemes we're bringing
people in from very challenging parts of
the world in some cases there's a lot of
cost attached to coming here and last
year as an example with the crops the
fruit and vegetables and flowers we
wasted 60 million pounds worth of high
quality fruit and vegetables so it's
really important that we have a seasonal
workers scheme that runs for nine months
of the year the current ones for six
months we know who's coming here we know
when they go back again but we can be
under no illusions that this is this is
challenging and this is costly and and
government continues to talk about low
skilled work picking our fruit and
vegetables is highly skilled and we need
to I think recognize the value of these
jobs if we're going to inspire a UK
Workforce to want to do them so we need
to to really focus I think on the skill
sets that we need in this Countryman the
Home Secretary saying well you don't
need to bring people in to do those jobs
you've got enough Brits here to do them
we simply do not have enough people
unemployed at the moment to do the jobs
that are available and as I said we've
actively incentivized people out of
doing these jobs into going to
University upskilling don't do
low-skilled jobs I think we've really
got to Value these jobs because they are
absolutely essential to our everyday
lives so you know not everybody wants to
go to university if we are going to
change our ambition for what we want in
this country if we're going to grow our
own Workforce effectively then we need
to inspire people that actually these
are great jobs and this is about a
progressive ladder that you can climb
with with job opportunities better use
of apprenticeship Levy and all of those
sorts of things it's it's no good to
keep saying it's low skilled it's
unimportant it's highly important John
is high skilled do we have to accept
that food prices are going to be more
expensive
I think there's a real challenge when
you look at what has happened we have
had the most affordable food in Europe
for a very long time we still do have
the most affordable food here per income
spend and we're the third most
affordable in the entire world so that's
really good for consumers but these
costs this war in Ukraine
it is a game changer I think and and
food prices have been very low for a
very long time I think that's been
challenging for everybody in the supply
chain for farmers and Growers all they
want is a fair return for for what they
are doing and for any business if you
know it is costing you more than you can
sell it for obviously you're going to
contract which is why we're saying the
lowest level of tomatoes cucumbers why
we had a billion less eggs last year so
we've got to find ways of having a food
policy a plan that actually deals with
the things the market doesn't want to
pay for that eases the cost of inflation
that means that we can keep producing
more because I think the weather events
that we're facing into Morocco in the
early part of the year you know
everybody face rationing of salads we've
got a great climate here
fundamentally Above All Else the summit
today should be about really being
positive about our own production it's
the largest manufacturing sector food
and drink and farming being probably the
last and remaining primary manufacturing
sector because right across the country
so I hope today is a real change of
agenda from government and that will
have it annually every year now it's
something that your members weren't
particularly
um want as we know but you know the
Prime Minister would say in response
meat is going up it's doubled in price
he's done a deal to make sure that lamb
can come from the other side of the
world why is it still so much more
expensive
so we've had three different Prime
Ministers all with completely different
priorities so Australia and New Zealand
were going to be fully liberalized deals
in 15 years time
the trans-pacific deal which we see
sunak has led on with with Kami badnock
has been a different approach with
recognizing sensitive sectors but as you
rightly say a lot of the damage is done
with a fully liberalized policy so it's
it's going to be I think challenging
going forwards but the you know the
British public have been incredibly
loyal to buying British they recognize
the challenges of climate change of
wanting to buy local every retailer I
speak to says all of our consumers say
we want to buy British we want to buy
local food miles matter so you know
Traders trade is a good thing but you
have to balance how you're trading you
have to make sure you have the same
values for other countries that you have
here if you don't you just undermine
your own production here it doesn't
matter whether that's cars whether
that's Furniture whether that's food you
want to have a common approach
have you been to Downing Street before
I have I met with the Prime Minister
just before Christmas okay
um and I have met with previous Prime
Ministers there as well but this is the
first time we've had a summit that
brings everybody together so I hope that
will last and happen every year